speaking to reporters by video link the
frustration of the un secretary-general
was clear it's well over a month since
he demanded a global ceasefire but the
fact the UN Security Council has been
unable to pass a resolution was the
result of what he called a dysfunctional
relationship between the major powers
and that makes it difficult for the
Security Council to decide as it makes
it difficult in many other areas for
international cooperation to work
secretary-general given the scale of the
pandemic do you believe that global
leadership has been adequate it is
obvious that there is a lack of
leadership it is always obvious
international community is divided in a
moment where it would be more important
than ever to be United there is indeed a
problem of leadership or if you want a
disconnect between leadership and power
we see remarkable examples of leadership
but they are usually not associated with
power and where we see power we
sometimes do not see the necessary
leadership I hope this will be overcome
sooner rather than later at a Security
Council session this week a very public
demonstration of the disagreements among
the world's top countries as the UN
Syria special envoy spoke during the
virtual event one of the ambassador's
had not muted his microphone the French
ambassador was on a separate phone call
on the where everyone else could hear
him his words were very telling he
talked to problems related to the w-h-o
and then starts to talk about the
Americans before he's alerted to the
fact he's unmuted in that moment the
Ambassador inadvertently revealed in
public the problems the UN Security
Council has been facing in trying to
come up with a resolution on kovat 19
the French have been leading those
negotiations for weeks diplomats say
it's a tortuous process the u.s. is
objecting to any reference in the
resolution to the World Health
Organization after President Trump
pulled funding from the global health
body meanwhile russia's Foreign Minister
Sergey Lavrov has been pushing the idea
of a meeting of the five permanent
members of the Security Council Russia
China the US UK and France that leader
level it still though hasn't happened
James BAE's al Jazeera of the United
Nations